Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
I'm Justin,
and today I want to talk about dreams.
How do we dream what we dream about?
Why do we dream?
Is there a point of dreaming and so forth?
So to understand dreams,
you have to,
of course,
first understand sleep.
Sleep in general has always been kind of a mystery to science.
Why do we need to enter a state that makes us unconscious and paralyzed for
eight hours every night?
If you think about it,
that's kind of dangerous and sleep is dangerous.
You could be attacked or eaten or something during sleep out in the wild.
From a Darwinian perspective,
though,
you could infer from the fact that sleep is so common place in the animal
kingdom.
The majority of animals do it.
In fact,
that it must be crucial for some reason the animals which entered the state,
which you would expect as a dangerous state out in the wild,
actually end up having some sort of survival advantage over those that did not.
Research has furthermore shown that sleep is indeed vital to our health.
It is arguably as important as consuming foods.
So yes,
that awful feeling you get of waking up at six in the morning is completely
justified.
You are in the middle of something important.
The body and the brain regenerating process a lot in multiple ways during sleep.
The focus of this video is of course on the brain.
A lack of sleep is not a small issue.
Going for long periods of time without it will eventually lead to very poor
health and eventually or death,
either indirectly or directly death from exhaustion as it's known.
This only reinforces the fact that all the things that go on during a sleep are
absolutely necessary to your survival and the body.
Scientists are getting a better picture of why sleep evolved.
Muscle grows,
wounds heal,
more hormones get synthesized and a lot of other bodily maintenance takes place.
The brain during sleep is more of a juggle to understand that when a very major
clue to this puzzle is of course dreaming.
Dreams have fascinated humankind for as long as we have record.
Even going back to ancient Sumeria,
there are clay tablets of people discussing their dreams.
Most cultures have seen them as very relevant,
much more than just random useless night thoughts.
Dreams can be vibrant,
brutal,
intense,
beautiful,
calming,
terrifying,
utterly nonsensical,
and yet seemingly meaningful.
We experienced situations,
people,
places,
emotions,
events,
et Cetera,
that we are familiar with.
And also ones which we are not.
People across the world have associated dreams with religious or supernatural
beliefs,
stating at their messages from deities or from the deceased or from the soul.
Some believe their images from a past life or visions of the future or things of
that nature.
Scientific Study of dreams called on neurology from the Greek word for dreams on
Narron.
However,
it didn't really take off until the 19th century or so early scientific research
into dreams spearheaded by psychologists such as Sigmund Freud and Carl Jung was
significant in that it turned dreams over to the field of science.
Yet admittedly much of what they and others at the time believed about the
nature and purpose of dreaming was proven to be false.
Though what they believed,
dreaming has formed the backbone of a considerable amount of modern
pseudoscience related to dreaming,
some of which remains commonly believed.
We spend a large amount of our lives dreaming about six years from two hours of
dreaming that we'd do each night.
Contrary to popular belief,
it's very rare to not actually dream every night.
Some people truly just a nut dream.
Others have experienced a form of brain damage,
which prevents it.
But the vast majority of the time we have multiple dreams at night.
We just don't recall them.
About 95% of dream content is a race within 10 minutes of waking up.
If the dream is even profound enough to remember and they usually are not cause
this is because of neurotransmitters involved in forming memories are suppressed
during sleep.
Furthermore,
as you may have noticed,
humans are not the only animals who are believed to dream.
We don't know what other animals like your dog,
cat,
mice,
birds,
et Cetera,
drum about.
There's no real way to tell objectively,
but there's a lot to suggest that they do indeed dream.
Even though dreams can have a profound impact on us,
we might expect science to condemn the imagery and sensations and such things
that occurred during the state when our brains are shut off as useless and
meaningless.
However,
to begin,
it's actually not correct to say that the brain shuts off during sleep.
Obviously people don't mean literally being literally shut off would suggest
brain death,
but even figuratively,
it's incorrect.
The only time your brain is actually shut off is during a coma or a similar
state like being under anesthesia.
Consciousness obviously shuts off different areas of the brain and to rearrest
mode,
but your brain is actually very active during sleep and it actually goes through
several stages of sleep.
Three stages of what is called an rem,
non rem sleep and rem one two and three stage three being also called slow wave
sleep and including the former category of non rem for and rem sleep.
Rem stands for rapid eye movement sleep.
It got this name because if you actually look at a person's eyes during this
stage,
they're typically darting all over the place.
Although if you accidentally wake them up while viewing this condition,
it might be a little bit awkward if the first thing they see is you staring at
them.
I'm sure though that the excuse that it's for science will work out just fine.
These stages were identified in the 1950s and the most interesting stage with
regard to dreams is rem sleep.
The dreams of rems seem to be the most intense animated,
an intriguing,
and therefore the greater portion of scientific study is focused on the dreams
that occur during rem sleep.
We cannot,
however,
leave out the activity in dream content of non runners sleeps specifically stage
three of an rem sleep because it's of course equally important.
You may already have actually recognized the difference between dreams that
occurred during an rem and rem without even knowing it.
Think of the dreams you have during a short nap,
maybe a half hour or so versus those during a full night's sleep.
Usually the story like maybe sometimes realistic dreams that you remember when
you wake up happened during rem sleep as to the more random imagery and mundane
situation in such things that happened and and rem sleep to elaborate,
here's what happens when you fall asleep,
you begin progressively going to the three stages of an rem sleep,
your heart rate,
breathing temperature and all that progressively drop.
It's during this and rem sleep that your body does.
A lot of its repairs and growth.
Dreaming does technically occur in all stages of the first two stages and rem
one and two are different.
In Stage one,
participants in dreaming studies that are awakened and his faith report a mix of
dreaming but also some call it thinking it's a semiconscious relaxed state,
but the dreams are the product of a city brain and are therefore considered a
form of dreaming.
You may also experience what a called hypnic jerks in the stage such as a
falling sensation that's suddenly awakens you or hearing voices or other noises
that are not actually there.
Don't let these things bother you too much.
They'll be sensations are completely normal in an rem to you begin to tune out
the external world.
Dreaming is rare and rum too,
but it is often like those of an rem one.
When dreams occur by an rem three you are in a considerably deep sleep at this
point and it is when the majority of non rem dreams occur around an hour or an
hour and a half into sleep.
Your body enters their rem stage,
your breathing and heart rate and things like that.
Pick back up when you went to rem,
but more interestingly,
your brainwaves are very close to those of your waking state because the
brainwaves are so similar to your waking state.
In fact,
the brain enters what is called rem,
a Tonia.
You probably know this better by the name is given when you consciously
experience it.
Sleep paralysis,
sleep paralysis is very uncomfortable to those who experienced it,
but it is a necessary function.
Without this mechanism,
you would act out your dreams and in fact people with a sleep disorder that
prevents this paralyzed state do sometimes act out their dreams.
It isn't your standard sleepwalking.
Sleep.
Walking usually occurs in stage three of an rem sleep and is believed to have
little to do with dreaming.
It's fairly different from what is called RBD or rapid eye movement,
sleep behavioral disorder where people act out their dreams and talk or eat or
fight,
et cetera.
Both sleepwalking and rem and rem sleep can be dangerous and has even led to
homicides in the past,
which I'll discuss in a future video.
Becoming conscious during Brehm a Tonia and experiencing sleep process,
as I said,
is often pretty wack.
It's when you're kind of awake but still paralyzed in your bed.
Some people such as myself,
notice it becomes somewhat uncomfortable but then usually drift back to sleep.
For others.
It is a terrifying experience.
It's believed to be the source of a lot of alien abduction reports or ghost
interaction reports,
but it's not aliens.
It's just the paralysis from rem sleep is still active or maybe sometimes it's
aliens that Kelly's say,
but we'll look more into sleep disorders and sleep paralysis and lucid dreaming,
which takes place during Rem Sleep and night terrors which should not and all
that sort of thing.
Coming up here back to dreaming itself.
You spend around 10 minutes in this rem sleep stage and then it ends and the
hour and a half sleep cycle.
Then repeat itself.
Rem Sleep typically tends to get longer after each cycle and assuming you get
these suggested eight hours of sleep that I'm sure many of us would like to
actually get.
You'll go through this cycle about four to five times in the night.
The rem stage gets longer after each cycle.
Other side with the last rem period being the longest and fascinatingly,
research seems to suggest that your dreams are the most vibrant,
intense,
and in fact the easiest to recall during this last rem cycle as opposed to your
first rem cycle.
If You keep a dream journal as I do,
it may interest you to record when you record her dreams.
See if they're from the latter halves of your sleep.
Interestingly,
you entered longer periods of end room,
three sleep during the earlier portion of your sleep and gradually have shorter
ones.
However though the end room three periods at the end of the night or shorter,
if you have a dream in the end run three stage,
it's usually toward the end of the night,
which may be related to the increasing intensity of Rem.
There are a number of theories that attempt to explain why dreams occur.
Some state that dreams are a byproduct of important processes in the brain,
but others say that dreams themselves are important for the more.
This question becomes even more complex as we have different types of dreams in
dreams.
In different stages of sleep to understand them.
We have to look at a source.
Dreams do not originate from just one part of the brain.
Several parts of the brain contribute.
However,
there was a big emphasis on the brain parts involved in various kinds of
memories like your hippocampus and cerebellum.
Sleep in general is considered by may scientists to be very important in what is
called memory consolidation.
You brain reviews information is gathered throughout the day and sorts it.
It strengthens information to finds useful but it tends to delete information
that I consider is unnecessary.
For example,
your brain may run through the routes you take to get to your classes at school
over and over during a sleep.
However,
other information like the color of the shirt to professor is wearing on the
first day may get deleted.
This footage from experiments undertaken by Matt Wilson shown at the world
science festival shows a video of a rat moving through a maze,
but dots you see on the maze and to the left are displays of the brain cells
that fire when the mouse reaches that specific area.
Wilson and other researchers then sent them mouse through the maze a second time
and the computer attempted to predict where the mouse was based off the brain
cells that at red roof firing alone.
Now typically impressively the Blue Arrow matches up with where the mouse is,
but occasionally as you can see,
the mouse will stop and an Arrow of flash behind it or ahead of it's showing
that the mouse is thinking about going through the entire maze as a whole,
forming a mental picture of the whole thing.
The third video,
however,
is the most interesting one here.
Researchers are monitoring the rat's brain as it's sleeping and finding that the
brain cells specifically involved in running through the maze are firing over
and over again very quickly.
It runs through the maze route mentally,
sometimes even backwards to strengthen the memory of the route.
There is of course more than just observation.
Studies have shown that interrupting sleep can affect performance on things like
memory,
examinations of all kinds.
However,
specific types of memories are believed to be related to specific stages of
sleep.
This can be kind of confusing,
but I'll try to elaborate and rem three seems to be closely related to
consolidating what is called declarative memory.
This has to do with facts,
information,
experiences in such things learned throughout the day consciously.
Likewise on scientific tests,
people who are deprived of an rem sleep sleep seem to do worse on tests
involving recalling information and memorization and things like that than those
who are allowed it.
If you're learning to play an instrument,
your brain may run through the experiences of that lesson at night.
However,
the specific procedural memory of playing that instrument is reviewed during rem
sleep.
Again,
where your body's paralyzed,
who eventually from reenacting things,
the actual steps,
the muscle memory,
the unconscious details,
et Cetera to play the instrument are viewed here.
Studies again show that shorten apps seem to have no effect on the performance
of certain tasks like riding a bike or playing an instrument.
However,
after a few periods of rem sleep,
there is a noted improvement.
Furthermore,
other parts of the brain involved in emotion such as the Amygdala and other
parts involved with memory and other areas of the limbic system are activated
more in Rem sleep as well.
This actually seems to be very relevant in reports of dream content.
Dreams from an rem three are very often related to waking life aspects of your
life that are currently affecting you and things of that nature.
If you're learning Italian,
for example,
you may dream about Italy speaking Italian being there walking by the leaning
tower of Pisa,
viewing the art of Italy,
eating the food of Italy,
et Cetera,
all while in and rem three.
These dreams while interesting are not usually very vibrant or emotionally
captivating and are much less memorable,
often described compared to rem dreams as a mundane procedural memory,
often called implicit memory refers to the unconscious information obtained
throughout the day and this is the information which is consolidated and rem,
but also keep in mind emotional consolidation occurs during rem as well and a
rem dream after the same day.
You may find yourself as a Roman general being elected a new pope or flying in a
contraption made by Leonardo Da Vinci.
This may not really even feature much of the Italian or the aspects of Italy
that you've learned about early in the day.
It may go completely off course.
It's worth mentioning also that infant's spend much more time about 50% of the
sleep and rem sleep.
It's held that baby's sip a considerable amount of time in general because their
body is growing.
It's entirely plausible that they enter rem sleep so frequently because of
neurostimulation from rem sleep is growing their brains and some passion.
Some theories hold that while your brain is organizing memories and going
through information you've learned throughout the day.
It's sending out signals that the rest of your brain is reading.
Different parts of your brain are activated,
memory centers,
emotional centers,
things like that,
and it creates a dream from these signals to make sense of them.
Furthermore,
supporting this theory is the fact that external stimuli sounds sensations and
the real world like a dog barking outside of foul smell in the room or fitting
hot.
Haven't noted affect on dream content though the external world can affect our
dreams.
Dreaming is indeed something which occurred internally,
not from external stimuli.
During all of this,
your prefrontal cortex and what's referred to as the left brain that have to
deal with planning and critical thinking and logic and things like that are
pretty inactive.
These brain structures aren't there to cross check information and it must
referred to more as the right brain has a wider range,
so a giant three had duck or snoop Dogg as a Jedi.
Knight is fair game.
The dominance of the right brain and dreaming can be shown not only from the
lack of logical patterns in the chaotic nature of dreams,
but less emphasis on reading actual words in such things for the more the areas
involved with certain parts of self awareness or also turned off being of course
unnecessary as well in the state,
meaning you're not easily able to tell that you are in a dream or an unusual
reality.
Individuals who have suffered brain damage to the area involved with his self
awareness may notably have trouble distinguishing between dreams and waking
life.
The similarity between the waking brain and the rem brain may also contribute to
why you feel conscious in your dreams.
In a sense,
you are conscious just in an altered state of consciousness.
Most notably without logic or self awareness,
which makes dreams seem even more mysterious and cool though or dream content is
often nonsensical.
The emotions we feel in dreams or not,
it's been suggested that the driving force of dreams are our emotions and the
things we dream of our responses.
It does emotions rather than emotions being responses to what we dream of.
Basically series that revolve around this information hold.
A dreaming itself doesn't have a specific function.
It's a byproduct of another specific function called an epic phenomenon.
That process,
again being the various forms of memory consolidation that activate other parts
of brands.
Well,
considering the differences of the memory consolidation processes and
understanding that in rem sleep areas of the brain involved in procedural
memory,
emotional memory as well as creativity and abstract thinking are activated.
In fact,
some areas like the hippocampus and Amygdala are even more active in Rem sleep
and during wakefulness.
It's no surprise.
The dreams report during rem sleep are often much more profound and memorable
and colorful while and rem three dreams which tend to review snapshots of
information throughout the day are more relevant to daily life,
but less interesting stuff though the rem brain is the most similar to the
waking brain in general.
The brain activity and and rum three's a little bit more like wakeful thinking
while the brain activity and rem is a little bit more chaotic and disorganized.
That mouse we mentioned earlier was probably in an rem three reviewing the maze
over and over again in a fast process.
In Rem sleep memories are played out as if they were actually occurring in real
time.
Is that truly the end of the story though?
But dreams are the interesting yet essentially useless byproducts of your doing
a recap of your day.
There are of course other theories.
Rem Sleep not only aids in the performance,
certain tasks,
but also some studies seem to suggest that it helps with creativity.
Could dreaming play a role in this.
Some postulate that perhaps dreaming as a part of the brain's attempt to take
the information is sorting through during a sleep and connected to and compare
it with other memories and information in the brain.
Some add onto this that with the prefrontal cortex being offline,
there is a wider opportunity for creativity to run free and random association
has to be made which could have evolved to help in waking life.
Many people through history have attributed inventions,
ideas,
works of art and other epiphany's and creations to having come from dreams.
Granted,
we have to keep in mind however,
that these people were quite frequently already toying with the concepts that
they'd eventually contribute to and would have continued to regardless of the
dreams,
but it's worth considering the possible inspiration that may have come from them
and the potential creativity boosts Debbie get from dreaming that may greatly
influence our waking lives or as some hold have helped our ancestors survive.
We must also keep in mind however that while rem sleep can be shown to influence
creativity,
dreams may again just be the byproduct of this process and not actually
definitely a part of the creativity boosts that we get from rem.
Yet some theories do hold that dreaming itself is inherently useful to our
survival and may have evolved.
Specifically the basis of these theories revolves around what we do.
Move out.
I'll go over specific dream content statistics in a moment,
but for now it will suffice to say that a substantial portion of our dreams,
especially in childhood are on average very negative.
Why it's theorized that dreams have evolved as a kind of simulation to practice
for the real world.
These negative dreams are very often related to the negative things in our
waking life.
Children may dream of monsters and being lost and losing their parents and the
fears that we would expect children to have adults stream about accidents,
failures at work,
divorce and breakups and things like that.
This may have evolved as a way to run through things to get a feel for them
before you actually have to go out and face them.
Dreaming About Encountering Wolves or bears,
it's such things may have helped our ancestors deal with the situations when
they arose,
thus helping their survival thus meaning dreaming itself is evolutionarily
advantageous.
Perhaps even today.
Those dreams about this speech you have to give or the arguments with their
coworkers may help you handle those situations in the real world as well.
However,
again,
it's worth reiterating that with the logical and supper where parts of your
brain being off these things may not always make sense.
You may dream of your father dying when your father is perfectly healthy or
getting fired when you're an excellent employee and certainly you may dream
about being haunted by ghosts even when you dump and even them.
If this theory is valid,
the brain would just be running through uncomfortable things,
not necessarily assessing the likelihood of them occurring.
This theory is supported by the finding that people undergoing stresses in life
may dream more option than otherwise content people.
Many explanations have been offered as to why we dream,
but these are the most likely and consistent with science regardless of whether
or not dreams evolved for a reason or are a byproduct,
but processes,
which of all for a reason we can not deny that dreams have is sort of relevance
to us in our waking lives and that there is a potential to peer into them and
learn from them.
Since we dream about things relevant to our lives and the states of mind and
experiences we have effect or dreaming does what we dream about reflect who we
are and where lives are.
Let's talk now not just about dreaming from the outside but the inside what
we're dreaming about.
As mentioned,
the majority of our dreams across the world are negative,
negative life circumstances and mental illnesses.
In such things tend to cause more negative dreams while higher satisfaction with
life seems to correlate with fewer negative dreams.
Both participants in studies as well as researchers stress a difference between
a negative dream and the nightmare.
Negative dreams are commonplace considerably.
Disquieting or uncomfortable dreams.
Nightmares are less commonplace.
Studies that are taken by Ernest Hartman seem to suggest that people who suffer
from mental illness,
unhealthy social life,
excessive stress,
and even individuals who attempt suicide have higher rates of nightmares than
the average men feel aggression in dreams much more commonly than women do and
dream about other men more commonly than women do.
Women tend to have more dreams involving people they know in places that are
familiar with and typically have more characters in the dreams.
All together,
both teenagers and the elderly seem to have similar dreams.
However,
the elderly report fewer dreams involving aggression and negative emotions.
In general,
research also seems to suggest that we have an easier time recalling her dreams
as we age,
even though children who spend more time in rem sleep and adults,
I thought to dream more in three fourths of our dreams,
there is at least some consideration given to how other characters and our
dreams feel about us.
We tend to only dream of essentially exact replays of our waking lives 1.4% of
the time.
According to some studies,
however,
65% of our dreams have they considered relevant to an individual's life by
reporting study participants.
This means that we dream of things related to our waking concerns,
but not as much our waking concerned and exactness.
Basically,
if you're learning guitar,
you're much more likely to dream of yourself playing in a band on stage.
Then going through the steps of learning a song to learn that day.
This is believed to be related to how the brain processes memory during sleep.
We are also present in the vast majority of our dreams and generally are on
surprisingly the main characters.
Sexual content is much less common in our dreams and we might expect only about
10% of dreams features sexual content on average,
and this is most common in adolescence.
Sexual Dreams May at times result in what is called a nocturnal emission or a
wet dream,
which is an orgasm that occurs during sleep.
Men tend to dream about sex more often than women,
but neither men nor women seem to even usually dream about their partners in sex
dreams.
Women only have dreams involving current or past partners in 20% of their sex
Men only 14% of the time,
men have higher tendencies of dreaming of multiple partners,
women of celebrities.
Evidently 12% of our dreams occur in black and white.
However,
this is a much lower statistic than from earlier decades,
and in fact,
only 4.4% of people under the age of 25 report dreams in black and white today.
This is likely linked to the development of color television.
Individuals who had been blind from birth also report dreaming.
So naturally they did not dream of visual content.
Not surprisingly,
not only do we tend to have similar emotions and general events occur across the
world and our dreams,
but we also dream of similar specific situations.
Being chased seems to be one of the most common types of dreams along with being
nude in public,
being excessively late to something very important,
such as an exam because of obstacles or being lost,
discovering new rooms or new aspects about a familiar environment being
destroyed by an unstoppable disasters.
How does a tidal wave or the end of the world and both the deceased being alive
and dreams as well as living,
dying and dreams?
It's not uncommon for dreams to be repetitive.
Around 67% of adults report having experienced them at least once in their
lives.
Perhaps you may throughout the course of a few days or even weeks or more have
very similar or repetitive dreams or at least dreams involving similar motions,
events and sensations.
Many of these repetitive dreams involved the themes that I just mentioned and
are usually negative on.
Surprisingly,
if you dream about the same things repeatedly,
these subjects are often occupying your waking of mine as well.
Dreaming of trouble at school,
missing classrooms,
spending tests,
et Cetera,
is often linked to actual stress over some aspect of school.
Dreaming of being overwhelmed by a great force like a tidal wave may be
indicative of being overwhelmed by something in waking life.
Dreaming of a deceased friend or family member may indicate that their law still
has a significant impact on you.
Statistics like these simply reinforced the notion that dreams are a window into
different parts of our mind.
We can use statistics like these with regard to the psychology of people on the
macro scale,
but you are able to do the same perhaps in even greater detail on your own by
keeping a dream journal.
I keep a dream journal for these reasons and that isn't just about recording
dreams.
A large part is analyzing the content.
Recording dreams as soon as you wake up is crucial because again,
you forget huge chunks of your dreams within 10 minutes of waking up.
Generally,
I don't actually write it out.
I usually just make notes that refer back to specific details and then go back
to bed.
Then later write it out in detail.
From there.
I will then analyze her aspects.
Look for the people and your dream,
their relation to you,
how you feel about them,
what they're doing,
et cetera.
Look at your environment.
Do you dream often and work school,
your parent's house.
What emotions have you felt in a dream?
Anger,
anxiousness,
happiness?
Does it start off negative,
but then you find a sense of comfort.
Finally,
highlight specific themes.
If one dream you dream of an argument with your parents,
another dream of yourself in a war and in another dream you find yourself in a
fight at school.
This was suggest that you regularly dream of conflict after multiple dreams,
probably at least 30 begin tallying up your statistics and analyze them.
Compare them to population averages.
See what you're doing about and what these dreams may mean.
The master of dream according was a man named Kalvin s hall.
He collected more than 50,000 dreams from people in scientific studies
throughout his life and developed a way to analyze them.
Also note,
I do mean to be careful using the word mean religious or spiritual leafs that
dreams carry inherent meaning will not be disrespected in this video.
However,
they will not be covered in detail here.
Scientifically speaking,
things such as prophetic dreams or a metaphorical dreams are not typically held
in high regard.
If you dream of an ambulance passing the street,
for example,
you may wonder if this is your subconscious attempting to send you a message.
When your friend asks for help through a difficult time,
you may believe that this is what the dream was indeed referring to the
subconscious realization that your friend would need help.
However,
if you were to break your arm that week,
if your grandmother were to pass away,
if you were to need a bandaid on a wound,
if you had to ask your coworkers for help for something at work,
if you were to donate to charity,
et Cetera,
you could say that any of these events are what the ambulance was predicting.
Meanwhile,
the other dreams you've had this week are ignored when they point to nothing.
It's for this reason which has been observed in various forums and scientific
studies that scientist are distrustful of prophetic or metaphorical dreams.
The mind may indeed symbolize things in dreams,
metaphorically.
However,
it's very lucky,
less of a subconscious attempt to send a complex message as a conscious mind,
but more reflection of what is going on in your mind altogether.
Because the logical planning decision making parts of our brain are off during
sleep.
We typically feel more like a character in our dreams and ourselves even when
they occur in the first person.
Some people,
however,
are able to exercise a degree of awareness in our dreams and maybe even take
control of her parts of the dream content and the direction that dream takes.
This is known commonly as lucid dreaming.
Lucid dreaming may sound like pseudoscience,
but there is actually scientific backing for some of it.
The concept of lucid dreaming dates back to the ancient Greeks,
but modern understanding of it began in the 19th century.
In 1867 the marquee doc feed the soul.
Denny published the book [inaudible] [inaudible] critique dreams and the ways to
direct them.
Practical observations.
In this book.
He not only discusses his experiences with lucid dreaming,
but also instructs readers on how they may learn to do it themselves.
In 1913 the term lucid dreaming was coined by Friedrich von Aden,
a Dutch psychiatrist.
I have personally never had a lucid dream.
I have had dreams in which I realized within the dream that I was dreaming,
but there was a certain criteria that you have to meet before a dream is
considered a lucid dream.
Paul,
totally a German psychologist has laid out seven conditions which must be met
before you're dreaming is considered lucid dreaming.
One awareness of the dream state to awareness of the capacity to make decisions.
Three awareness of memory functions for awareness of self.
Five,
awareness of the dream environment.
Six awareness of the meaning of the dream and seven awareness of concentration
and focus.
The basic concept of lucid dreaming being in a form of a conscious state while
dreaming has been confirmed by science.
Lucid dreams are the most common in the final stages of rem,
wherein of course we have the most vivid and detailed dreams.
Researchers such as Steven Laberge,
the founder of the Lucidity Institute have designed experiments in which study
participants were given a prearranged signal to move their eyes.
When they were aware they were dreaming.
The study found that may participants were once they entered from sleep,
indeed giving the prearranged signal they were even able to count out 10 seconds
by moving their eyes in a specific way,
waiting 10 seconds,
then given the signal again,
which demonstrates to the passage of time and dreams is the same as in waking
life,
at least in rem dreams.
Lucid dreaming is described as somewhat precarious for beginners.
It relies on finding a balance between consciousness and dreaming in which there
is a tendency to either wake up or lose consciousness again and returned to
normal dreaming.
At times,
this can even trigger say paralysis like we talked about earlier,
which is not commonly experienced at lucid dreamer they're going for,
it's of course,
much less enjoyable.
Generally a number of methods are employed to help lucid dreamers or own Niara
knots,
as they call themselves,
apparently achieved the state,
one of which is to look at once hand than to a clock or written word or
something.
Then back to the hand and back to the object again and the real world over and
over in the real world,
of course,
the clock or the writing will stay similar.
However,
because the left brain which interprets these things is less active during rem
sleep,
the word or time may change without logical structure.
When one looks back at them a second time,
which may then signal that the dreamer isn't a dream.
Lucid dreamers also suggest keeping a dream journal.
Another incentive to keep one,
like I mentioned earlier,
in order to become better familiar with and better at recognizing your dreams.
Science agrees that this leads to consciousness and dreams,
but it isn't quite as certain a dreamer as are able to control the events and
emotions.
Other dreams,
such a subjective experience is not easily studied objectively by science and
because of the nature of dreams.
Reports from dreamers are not always reliable.
Dream reports.
Lucid are not often lose information or contain errors and furthermore,
it is entirely possible that one may feel as though they are controlling the
dream when in reality it's is not the case.
However,
other researchers do disagree and continue to scientifically study the nature of
lucid dreaming.
Up to this point in the discussion,
dreaming has been treated as a scientific curiosity which we observe.
Some of our dreams are negative,
some are positive,
perhaps some we can even control.
They may affect us a great deal emotionally,
but regardless of what happens in our minds at night,
the vast majority of the time,
the vast majority of us get up,
forget about it and go about our days.
For some people,
it's not so simple.
People who suffer from sleep disorders or parasomnias can have a very
troublesome night and dreams can even play a role in the variety of things that
people with a few of these sleep disorders do during the night,
which we will now discuss.
Sleepwalking or some [inaudible] if you want to use a fancy Latin word,
as I mentioned,
doesn't take place during rem sleep as we might expect.
It takes place usually during the end run three stage and is most common during
the earlier sleep cycles.
When slow wave sleep as longer,
though we might reasonably assume that sleepwalking occurs because of dreams
activating a mind as psychologist used to dreams appear to have little to do
with sleepwalking.
Scientists are unsure of what exactly does trigger stick walking.
In fact,
a number of variables increase the risk of it.
It's believed to be at least partly genetic.
Your odds of bar can go up if your family members do it to some disorders like
anxiety disorders,
migraines,
Tourette's and schizophrenia also increase the odds.
Excessive stress,
excessive fatigue and drug use can increase the likelihood of sleep walking with
someone at risk.
However,
what exactly triggers a sleepwalking itself is unknown.
Scientists who have studied sleepwalkers report that brain activity reads
normally for slow wave sleep until suddenly heart rate increases.
Parts of the central nervous system become active and the person that comes to
active.
When sleepwalking and dreams Douche drama go together,
it's considered to be a different disorder,
one that occurs during rem sleep,
rapid eye movement,
sleep behavior disorder or Rpd.
Remembering that in rem sleep our brain resembles our waking activity is key to
understanding this disorder.
Normally we have the sleep paralysis to prevent us from acting out our dream.
It's about the cause of RBD is the disabling of Remy Tonia.
As a result,
people act out a dreams they may talk,
walk around,
eat cooked,
smoked cigarettes,
et Cetera,
and given the negative nature of dreams,
many of these occurrences are negative.
People may yell,
run,
jump,
punch,
fight,
throw things,
et Cetera,
which can harm not only them but people with whom they share a bedroom.
They may even hold conversations with people who are awake while they're still
asleep or interact with them in various ways.
Upon awakening,
people would typically claimed that they were dreaming these events and would
not know that they actually occurred.
Rbds noted as being either a symptom which precedes or follows.
Parkinson's.
Though there are many things which can cause it and it does not always lead the
Parkinson's sleepwalking in both slow wave sleep and rem is considerably
dangerous at times.
It has led to injuries,
deaths and even murder,
which I'll discuss in an upcoming video.
Focusing on parasomnia Slape talking or something.
ELOQUII is close to related to sleep,
walking and occurs in both rem and non rem sleep with differences again in both
but again is most common and and rum.
Three around 50% of children reportedly sleep talk at some point in their lives,
so the majority outgrow it and purity and room three sleep talking.
The most common form generally consists of nonsense or mumbling.
They'll allowed shouting or moaning as possible as well.
Sometimes the words that are related to a dream.
However other times it is not.
Night terrors are another disorder with some connection to dreams and night
terror is not just an edgy term for a nightmare.
It's a separate situation.
Night terrors occur during an rem three and nightmares typically during rem a
night.
Terror is a form of sleepwalking where an individual and as a panicked,
terrified states and begins to react to it.
This may last for a few minutes until the individual goes back to sleep because
night terrors occur and rung.
Three dreams are not always believed to be the regular trigger of them and when
they are related.
Victims of disorder cannot recall the incident at all the next morning usually
let alone the dream dreams,
whatever the content,
whatever their origins,
what have the purpose will likely captivate us for as long as we have them.
The fact that we are on the beginning,
our scientific investigation of them only adds to our mystery.
There are many things we still need to understand.
Many problems we still need to have clarified,
but perhaps for now we should sleep on it.
If you have anything to add about dreams or dream experience you'd like to
share,
I'd be glad to read it in the comment section below.
To support the creation of more videos like these I linked to patriotic,
we found a description or more videos like this and video some many other
subjects.
Be sure to check out the rest of fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.